fast for James cleverley being the
foreign secretary means dealing with
high pressure situations but like many
families his has been battling with
unimaginable pain his wife Susie who he
describes as his biggest support found
out she had breast cancer a year ago
this week we went on a special visit to
the foreign office to hear their story
Susie and James thank you for joining us
on the show today now James you are our
foreign secretary running one of the
great offices of State for government
but we're not here to talk about foreign
policy today although I might ask you
one question at the end we're here to
talk about Susie actually more about
your wife Susie and about your battle
with cancer and you're looking great and
you look so well now but it has been
quite a torturous Journey
so thank you for sharing your story and
raise an awareness for other women out
there and thank you for inviting us to
the beautiful foreign office but what I
wanted to do I thought what would be
nice would be to start at the beginning
because you two are renowned around
Westminster has been a very close couple
so let's start at the beginning how did
you both meet
we met at University it was the um my
first day of my first year and James was
working behind the bar
and I just met these new friends you
know and I was trying to impress them I
went to buy all the drinks and James
served me and um and I and I waited a
while to get my drinks you're a bit slow
because he told everybody don't serve
her I wanna I wanna serve her and I took
all the drinks and I went off and I
didn't really pay much attention I was
just so focused on you know my new
friends and um but you followed me
didn't you I did and came to chat to me
pretty cheesy chat up line what was that
I basically said you've got the most
gorgeous eyes I've ever seen in my life
right in front of her friends on her
first day at Uni yeah but she she does
still does and and they all kind of went
oh and just left us to it and and that
was it and that was it that was 29 years
ago and you just that was it you started
going out and that was it
uh nearly so this was lovely from our
site James
yeah I mean yeah I mean so I mean Susie
was and is absolutely stunning managed
to forget my wallet on our first date so
Susie had to pay for our first six
packages so I did my best to screw it up
but I think no it's yeah
and 29 years and you're you know you've
very much together you have two sons now
adults I think uh Rupert's just turned
18 your younger boy
um and James you were a minister in the
Johnson Administration back in 2021 your
boys were were growing up and then
everything changed for for you and your
entire family Susie when did you first
learn you were ill
it's almost a year to the day actually a
year ago on Sunday it was 13th of
November we were in Essex and I just got
up in the morning went to have a shower
and I was just letting the water run and
you know to get warm yeah and I just did
An Almighty stretch in front of the
mirror and and as I came back out up
from the stretch I just noticed
just really really was luck I noticed
the strange puckering on my skin
underneath my breast and I instantly
knew that's not right that's never been
there before so I went into James and
said have you seen this have you seen
this before and he was like No And we
were both like
this isn't this isn't right
but it was Saturday morning what can you
do on a Saturday morning so we just
thought let's just park it and enjoy our
weekend and the constituency and we had
we had quite a few events on I think
there was a remember it was a
remembrance Sunday weekend so we had a
number of things that we were going to
there and um I thought well I'll just
ring the doctors on the Monday morning
and that's what I did
and I nearly I nearly didn't it was just
James's look look at me on the Monday
morning he
you know we were busy it was what it's
like in the morning with getting
everybody ready the dogs
the kids all sorts and um James looked
at me and said don't forget to call the
doctor okay and you were so serious
and I just felt I need to and I did and
it all happened so quickly and it did
happen quickly so so that's November the
13th you noticed a puckering on your
breast yeah you phoned the doctor Monday
and then your diagnosis happened quite
quickly what's the third of December
yeah that I mean what so what was the
process I mean were you you must have
been were you frightened or did you just
try and put it to the back of your mind
and wait to see what the doctor said I
think the day I was really frightened
with the day I went to the doctor
because I knew something wasn't right
and okay and I I knew that puckering was
a sign for breast cancer and I I went to
my GP and I told him they were they were
amazing the reception said why you why
do you want to see the doctor and I said
explained what I'd found and she said
the doctor will need to see you today
the doctor will ring you between half
past eight and twelve at half past eight
on the dot the doctor rang me and said I
need to see you today when I explained
what it was and I said that's fine I can
be there in two minutes because we live
a few houses up from the doctors so I
whizzed round before he even started his
surgery and within seconds I was you
know he examined me he could feel a lump
I couldn't feel a lump right and he
could see the puckering of the skin and
he he said for what I can see and what I
can feel I think you do have breast
cancer but I'm going to refer you to the
breast clinic
take somebody with you it's probably
going to be bad news and okay I think
that's what he said
yeah you know I don't know because you
suddenly get hit by this
oh it's cancer
um and I don't really know if those were
the words but that's what I what I heard
and what I remember and I just came out
of there and I rang James who was on the
train into Westminster to here and
um I said I think it's cancer and I just
burst into tears and I think I cried
most of that day because it was a bit of
a shock and that was the time I was
really really scared yeah but then you
kind of you get used well I just got
used to it it's cancer
what can I do I can't do anything I've
just got to do as I'm told take the
medication and then
get there so you've got you're very
upset done with James what did you do
you're coming into work and seriously
friends with this bomber show and you've
what you have to go and just do your
days what I mean it must have been yeah
it was it was uh it was quite weird so
we'd come back to London
um because I was you know going to be
coming into Westminster as we as we
often do so I'd go on the Suburban train
to head into Westminster and
my plan had been Susie goes to the
doctor hopefully it's nothing to worry
about and I get on with my day
and Susie rang me and she said I've been
super doctor they're not happy they
think it might be cancer
and I said I'll come home I'll I'll turn
straight around I'll I'll come home so I
had to ring my private secretary at the
foreign office say look can you cancel
my meetings because I need to go home
and and he said is everything okay
Minister and I I tried to say
Susie might have cancer I I just
couldn't get the words out I I couldn't
speak
and I can talk
um but I just couldn't speak so I said
I'll text you and I texted him
um and you know this organization was
amazing Liz uh trust was my boss at the
time when she was front actually she's
absolutely amazing
um and um
and you know so councilman meetings and
went home talked to Susie we talked it
through I then tried to ring again to
explain what was going on and I still I
couldn't say it I couldn't say the word
I couldn't say the word so for the next
couple of hours everything was done on
on WhatsApp just explaining you know
apologizing for meetings I was canceled
um and it really hit me and I hadn't I'd
never felt anything like that before
I and because I was going to say Susie
the thing was you'll you got diagnosed
very quickly but it was it was an
aggressive cancer yeah yeah and three
types of breast cancer I didn't know you
could get three three types I didn't
know so what are they did you have the
most aggressive time I had I'm triple
positive
um so it responds to my hormones and her
too is Eastern progesterone and her too
and her too
is um I think that's the aggressive one
and 10 years ago there was no cure for
her too so I'm really fortunate that I
got it now the most frightening thing
was the word cancer yeah yeah
as soon as that was kind of
I was on board that I had cancer it yeah
and you've just got to go through it
through it but I wasn't scared when they
told me that I had but James you sort of
said how you couldn't actually even
verbalize what was happening to Susie
and the family you know you you've got
your sons your very tight family I mean
was this the first serious trauma the
family had had I mean was it the worst
thing that had happened to you both as a
couple would you say or it's I can't
I mean we've I've always regarded
myself as being lucky
um and that's not it's not that I
haven't had difficulties
um I mean my mum had breast cancer it's
quite funny it almost
you know so mum had breast cancer mum
passed away about seven eight years ago
nine years ago
um and you know it's we've had
difficulties in our life I mean like a
lot of people when we were a bit younger
um you know I I got made redundant at
one point so money was tight so we've
had we've had difficulties but you know
we have got a really really supportive
extended family on both both my side and
Susie's side so we've always been able
to get through but this I mean this this
this was different it really did feel
different and Susie you're as the
disease progressed it was rough wasn't
it can you talk to me a little bit about
that that Journey for you because your
treatment became almost on Battle it did
become unbearable didn't it in terms of
the side effects for you it did it was I
mean don't get me wrong people do get it
far worse than I had it but it was I it
was really tough
um I the first drug I was on
it hit me really hard every time I had
it I had it four times and it was every
two weeks and I would come home and two
hours later I'd be knocked out not I'd
have to go straight to bed I knew I had
to go to bed and I was I was quite ill
with it but I would slowly slowly get
better and over the couple of weeks I'd
slowly kind of feel like I was climbing
out of the hole and then you have to do
the next round and then you're hit again
but yeah if you did four lots of that
and then they moved you onto a different
drug didn't you yeah which was part of
the plan I was going on to another drug
um called dose taxol for another four
doses every three weeks
but I had a reaction to that and my face
um all sorts of I had a whole long list
of side effects but males yeah my nails
ever the reason they're painted is
because they're all black and falling
off I've lost two of my toenails
um and the sensitivity on my fingers is
is horrible and my feet but with that
drug my face bloomed and
um I was covered in hives that became
infected and
it was really really quite uncomfortable
and it looked pretty awful didn't I and
it was itchy and it was wasn't very nice
and they took me off it I also had
problems with my stomach and you also
talked about when we talked the other
day actually I saw your particle you
talked about and my friends having
treatment at the moment she's having the
same about the ulcers in the mouth yes
you you couldn't even eat or drink at
one point no that's right I couldn't and
I could it was very difficult to speak I
look back at some videos I've done
because I'm doing a video diary
and um
and yeah I couldn't speak I couldn't
move my tongue properly around my mouth
because my mouth was so sore
um and putting even putting a glass of
water to my lips was really painful the
water going in my mouth was really
painful it was yeah it was not nice did
you I know it's a you just have to go
through it don't you because you need to
get better but you must have felt quite
low did you withdraw you you did you
withdraw from Life a bit did you hide
away I mean how did you cope with that
well I didn't really do a huge amount
because I couldn't really do very much I
but I did walk my dogs every day
um and people would come and visit I had
a lot of support from family and friends
there was always somebody coming to see
me so I didn't go out a lot but I had a
lot of people coming to help me help me
around the house help me in the garden
um people cooked for me people turn up
with meals and the support has been
absolutely incredible really really
incredible and and James for you you're
here at the foreign office when this is
half and it happened you're working as a
minister did you at any point think I'm
going to have to take some compassionate
leave or even quit my job like I need to
politics is frenetic it never stops the
demands on you never stop did you think
actually Susie needs me more than the
foreign office needs me right now
so I I said to to Susie
um I I will do whatever I need to do and
I've and and Susie's always had a veto
on on my political career that's we I've
always said this can be really really
horrible and if at any point we had this
conversation long before the cancer I
always said if at any point you don't
want me to do this anymore
that's it I'll stop I'll I'll hand in my
papers and I'll stop
um and and so when this happened I you
know I said look I you know I
what do you want me to do and and Susie
said well look you know just keep keep
working
until I I yeah I need you to stop
working and say Liz was great and had a
conversation with Liz and I said look
this is a situation I want to keep
working but at some point and it might
be a quite short notice I'm gonna I
might need to take some time off and she
said look
keep working as normal until you can't
work as normal and then and then let me
know so she was she was great and as you
know the whips were great that you know
the PM was great
um
and I suppose trying to maintain some
normality in my life was was was was was
quite important but
um ultimately when when you went for
surgery uh and you did need a lot of
support you know getting dressed and
um and and walking and that kind of
stuff I I took some time off
but I mean for Susie's
you know she's strong like I am she
really I mean I was I mean I look back
now as I was amazed by how little time I
needed to take off and how determined
you were to recover but I mean that
period immediately for that couple of
weeks after the surgery was
that was really nice yeah what happened
what happened tell me about this so you
had a had an objective to me I think I'm
sexy on the right side of reconstruction
at the same time and they took my
stomach yeah stomach to create yeah the
breast
um but I I knew that that's when I'd
need him and I knew I wanted James to be
with me and and I knew it would take a
couple of weeks so that's why I just
wanted you to keep going
um and not be I didn't need him sitting
on you know worrying about me but the
surgery
the surgery was full on it was full on
but it's all manageable you know you
just you just
I didn't really think about it too much
I just did you did you think though did
you have moments where you thought am I
going to get through this am I going to
get better or did you always have it in
your mind that you will you would get
through it oh yeah I always thought I'd
get through it
I I'm quite a positive person I don't
even think there's another option
maybe at the beginning I was like oh
maybe this is it this is the end of my
road but as soon as I was on you know as
soon as I was seeing my consultant and I
was given my plan of the medication I
was going to be on I thought okay yeah
there's a there's a way out and and as I
say to people that it's like getting on
a roller coaster you just get on the
ride and you've got to gotta go with it
yeah if you try and fight it that's when
you get into trouble and I don't I don't
look to the Future not because I don't
think there's going to be one for me not
at all it's just because I just need to
take each day as it comes and get
through those moments I mean one of the
things that that really struck me is
that we referred to guys and St Thomas's
yeah uh Cancer Center
um and everybody all the various all the
various medical professionals from all
the various different teams and I lose
track of how many different bits of the
NHS work to do this every single one of
them were just incredibly professional
and that professionalism was just so
reassuring and and once people start
explaining this is what's happening this
is what we're going to
this is how it's going to work this is
what happens next
you know even though they're talking
about quite scary stuff it was
incredibly reassuring it was remarkable
it's striking how many people you find
out have either had breast cancer or
have someone close to them that's got
breast cancer that was one of the things
so it's it's much more prevalent than
than
I realized and having someone you love
go through it makes it makes it real
James did you ever think you might lose
Susie in this journey or did you always
think she'll be okay that may be the day
you found out
there have been a couple of times when
when I've had to like think about that
um
and it's weird because you know when
you're younger you go through big chunks
of your life that's not there's not
anything you ever think about
um and I you know and I hadn't thought
about my own mortality and I certainly
hadn't ever really given any thought to
losing Susie or
or what that might feel like and then
suddenly you've got to confront that
um
and as you say we are close
sorry
and
um the good thing is though the good
news is that you've had your treatment
and you've had your reconstruction
you've had your mastectomy and and how
are you now because you look great yeah
I feel great I feel so much more like me
I'm still having treatment I'm having
immunotherapy now and that'll be going
on until April and then I have another
operation that's more reconstruction to
finish off um I'm on the waiting list
for that but I feel I feel I feel great
I feel like me again I feel yeah I feel
like I can do things I can't do
everything that I used to be able to do
just yet because I'm not fit enough
haven't done anything for quite a while
but yeah I feel like I'm more like me if
you will indulge with the city we've run
out of time but James you are the
foreign secretary and I am with my other
hats on the political editor hopefully
we can do a proper sit down on politics
and foreign policy and all the time but
just just to ask you because I really
have to now I'm here just on Russia and
Ukraine we're at a phase in that war
where Putin's options appear to be now
heroin the Russians are now pulling out
of kios near Carson are we reaching the
point now where you think Russia is
losing that war
Russia started losing this war the day
their tanks rolled across the border
because
um it was clear that Putin expected that
President zielinski would be overthrown
that he could be replaced with some kind
of puppet leader that the ukrainians
would collapse their morale would
collapse and what happened is that they
were galvanized the International
Community came together and from that
point onwards
result was inevitable which was that the
ukrainians would succeed and we're now
seeing that played out
there are of course options for for
Putin and the most I think the best
option for him is to is to withdraw uh
is to allow the ukrainians to have their
country back
um and and the reason why that's the
best option is because it's clear the
International Community the UK very much
included in that we'll continue to
support the ukrainians until they
succeed and Russia is now interested in
talking isn't it I mean yeah and in the
ultimate
um withdrawal just one more thing does
that fit for you for president zielinski
that includes Crimea does it for the UK
government as well the decision about
this has got to be for the ukrainians
it's got to be for president zielinski
you know we will we will we will
continue to support the ukrainians until
this is until this is done and we're
absolutely not going to uh and no one
should dictate to the ukrainians uh what
the what the terms of any settlement
should be that will be for the
ukrainians do and we're going to
completely we're going to support them
and you're 100 I'm I'm out of time I'm
going to ask you one cheeky final
question
okay if you don't mind
um things have carved down a lot around
this place in Westminster I spoke to you
to remember the day that Rishi sunak was
anointed conservative party leader you
had backed Boris Johnson up to that
point James you you and he go back a
long way you've always been a key Ally
to him
um but now we've kind of got back to
stability and the sort of
that that period's over did you did you
regret a bit wanting to bring back the
Boris Johnson era well look as you said
work with them for over a decade
um and he supported me and I've
supported him uh but the point is he
chose not to stand that was his decision
his decision Alone
um Rishi has
I mean he's already demonstrated in what
has only been let's remind ourselves
only been a very very short time as
prime minister he's already shown
himself to be incredibly effective in
terms of putting some calmness and
stability back into the economic
situation I've just seen him at cop27
very very calm confident and assured on
the world stage I think the
Parliamentary party and and uh you know
the the The Wider party in the country
really rallying around him uh you know
I'm I I am absolutely completely
comfortable that he is going to be an
outstanding prime minister and Susie
this is about you this interview
even though he's the foreign secretary
you're the star of this show at the
moment I just want to ask you one more
thing you've been through this
incredible journey you've done it
clearly with great resilience what's for
women out there watching this that are
suffering from breast cancer might be
having horrible treatment right now
might be in some of the Dark Places
you're in what's your what's your
message what do you want to sort of say
to them
well use the resources there are so many
resources out there people to speak to
um when I was at a really
difficult moment I rang the acute
oncology and they said to me they were
just brilliant they'd said to me you
know you're going through so much but
don't worry things will get better and
just those words just made me
all the worry and not the worry just the
anxiousness and just just dissipated
um but but the thing to do is is it will
get well hopefully we'll get better just
keep going and be positive and um
I don't know it just
I don't know stick with it we're doing
it's not a nice Journey it's a really
tough road but you know I got I went
right down to the bottom but I did did
keep going and I got back up and now I'm
you know I'm nearly there I'm nearly
there so just there's some really tough
times but it does it can it will should
get better and I'm so glad I'm so glad
for both of you and your boys thank you
that you did get through the other side
so thank you so much uh for talking to
us today it's absolutely fascinating
thank you Susie thank you James thank
you thank you